hablemos un poco acerca de la ex ositos
y eso sí dosis y este es el proceso en
donde las células libera moléculas
grandes que pueden ser usadas por el
resto del cuerpo o por otras células o
que será parte de la matriz extracelular
y para entender cómo se lleva a cabo es
bueno pensarlo como lo opuesto a la
endocitosis primero se producen las
proteínas justo aquí en el retículo
endoplasmático este es nuestro ejemplo
clásico y estas proteínas después
saldrán dentro de una vesícula la que
tengo aquí y esta misma se fusionará con
el aparato de golgi lo tenemos justo
aquí y entonces en el aparato de golgi
las proteínas serán procesadas las
proteínas serán procesadas por aquí por
aquí van a ser procesadas y después
eventualmente saldrán del aparato de
golgi dentro de unas nuevas vesículas
estas que tenemos aquí las cuales harán
su camino para llegar a la membrana
plasmática a la membrana externa que
tenemos aquí
las vesículas lleguen sus membranas se
fusionarán con las membranas plasmáticas
y cuando sucede esto las proteínas que
estaban en estas vesículas serán
liberadas y esto es la exitosa es
clásica bueno también existen otros
casos donde las vesículas se fusionan
parcialmente con la membrana liberan su
contenido y después se desprenden de la
membrana a este mecanismo se le conoce
con el nombre de besa y corre pero el
clásico mecanismo este que estoy
poniendo justo aquí es donde las
vesículas se fusionan completamente con
la membrana endoplasmático déjame
ponerlo así entonces esta membrana que
tengo aquí se va a ver más o menos así
después de que se fusione con esta
vesícula que tengo aquí me quedaría algo
así algo así y ahora puedes observar que
esta parte de aquí va a ser la vesícula
que se fusiona que la membrana si estás
mi versículo entonces aquí se va a ver
de esta forma y bueno recuerda que ya
líbero aquí a la proteína que teníamos
atrapada en la vesícula así que la voy a
poner por aquí
la proteína va a ser usada en alguna
otra parte del cuerpo y quiero aclarar
algo esta membrana de la que ha hablado
varias veces en otros vídeos aunque la
estoy dibujando con una línea es una
aplica para fosfolípidos ya hemos
hablado de esto varias veces recuerdas
esta parte de aquí si la hacemos un
acercamiento se va a ver de la siguiente
manera el ejemplo para los 100 aquí
tendrían el acercamiento y entonces se
va a ver de esta manera vamos a tener
una bicapa fosfolípido acá estos son los
fosfolípidos que formaban parte de la
membrana de generarlos así que tengo
otro aquí tengo otro aquí tengo otro y
por acá bueno es una pick-up así que por
acá también voy a tener otro y otro y
otro y otro y esta vesícula que tengo
aquí se va a fusionar con la membrana
estas de acuerdo lo que quiero que notes
es que entonces se va a ver de la
siguiente manera aquí también vamos a
tener una bicapa fosfolípido acá pero de
la vesícula dejen ponerlos y aquí tengo
la pica para fosfolípido acá de la
vesícula entonces realmente quiero
enfatizar que ésta
líneas que estoy dibujando todas estas
líneas que tengo por aquí realmente
todas estas membranas que vemos son
capas fosfolípidos y déjame ponerlo así
para que observes que esto es un
acercamiento déjame ponerlo así y esta
parte va a ir para acá y esto es la
exitosa y clásica y una cosa que
encuentro bastante interesante es que
cuando aprendemos este proceso y lo
vemos dibujado como aquí decimos ok
estas vesículas aleatoriamente flotan
hasta llegar aquí a la membrana donde se
fusionan y libera su contenido pero
realmente no es tan caótico
todas estas vesículas van en pistas
recuerda que cuando hablamos del
citoesqueleto bueno este que no está
dibujado porque haya el esquema muy
desordenado se vería más o menos así por
todas partes aquí tenemos al sito
esqueleto déjame ponerlo más o menos así
todo esto está anclado en la célula hay
micro tubos hay microfilamentos también
tenemos filamentos intermedios tenemos
un buen de cosas aquí y todo esto no
sólo le da forma
la célula sino que también sirve para el
transporte
esta vez circula que tenemos aquí
seguramente viajó en algunas de estas
estructuras para llegar a la membrana y
no sólo esto también tenemos proteínas
motoras que usan atp para empujar la
vesícula hacia la membrana para que ésta
libere su contenido como si todo esto
fuera una fábrica y es que siempre que
pienso esto pienso que es algo bastante
racing ante porque siempre pienso que
dentro de nuestras células hay todo un
universo no son solamente una masa
amorfa tienen todas estas estructuras
todas estas proteínas que están a una
escala pequeña muy pequeña pero bastante
increíble y son capaces de hacer
procesos tan complicados lo que les
acabo de mostrar una vez más es la ex
ositos y clásica y ésta sucede cuando
hay proteínas y lípidos que produce la
célula y necesitan ser liberados de
alguna manera también suceden las
neuronas cuando se mandan señales
químicas de una neurona a otra
en este caso tendríamos esos hitos de
neurotransmisores que llegarán a la
siguiente neurona todos estos procesos
son bastante importantes recuerda que
nuestro cuerpo no funcionaría
correctamente o tal vez ni siquiera
funcionaría si no existieran la expósito
sis